Hi there everyone.
You probably noticed over the
past few weeks, I haven't been
producing any videos either
here on Numberphile or my
other channels.
That's not some bad omen
relating to the fact that our
last film was about
the number 6-6-6.
In fact, I've just
been on holiday.
I actually went and saw
something I've always wanted
to see, and that's
Mount Everest.
So before we get back into the
usual swing of things here on
Numberphile, I thought I'd
share a few numbery facts
about the biggest mountain
in the world.
So Mount Everest probably nudged
its way to become the
world's highest mountain about
200,000 years ago.
But of course, it wasn't
recognized as such until about
the mid 1800s during the Great
Trigonometric Survey of India.
Peering into the forbidden lands
of Nepal and Tibet from
nearly 200 miles away, I
should say, surveryors
calculated what they called
Peak B, or Peak 15, to be
exactly 29,000 feet high.
Now they didn't think anyone
would believe it was exactly
29,000 feet high, so
they published a
height of 29,002 feet.
That's 8,840 meters.
Now, the British weren't really
too clear on what the
local names were for
the mountain.
And that's still a reasonably
complicated debate today.
So they decided they'd name it
after the foremost survey
boss, a guy called George
Everest, or Everest as we call
it these days.
Now in the mid 1950s, not long
after the mountain had been
climbed for the first time, it
was remeasured and the more
accurate height of 8,848
meters was adopted.
That's the familiar number
many of us know today.
More precise measurements were
made in the 1990s, and things
didn't change very much, still
about 8,848 meters.
But in 1999, some Americans
came along using GPS.
And they put a spinner in the
works, publishing a new
height, 8,850 meters.
For many people, that
still stands.
Then in 2005, the Chinese came
along and published a lower
figure, 8,844 meters.
They said the snow cap on
top of the mountain
shouldn't be counted.
And they were using the
rocky summit instead.
Now Nepal doesn't accept
this argument.
They're sticking with 8,848.
Now more measurements are
planned at the moment.
These things are always
going on.
And it's also worth noting that
Mount Everest is actually
growing by about half a
centimeter, one centimeter
every year as the Indian
continental plate smashes into
China forcing the
Himalayas up.
In fact, in about a million
years, Everest would
theoretically be twice
as tall as it is now.
But gravity and earthquakes,
things like that are unlikely
to allow that to happen.
And of course, Everest is only
the king of the mountains when
measuring above sea level.
The highest mountain measured
from its base to its summit is
actually Mauna Kea in Hawaii.
Most of this mountain, of
course, is below the sea.
And the furthest point from
the center of the Earth is
actually the peak of this
mountain in Ecuador, which
benefits from the Earth's
bulging waistline.
But whatever the numbers say,
whatever definitions you like,
it's always going to be Mount
Everest that captures the
imagination of people like me.
Now there's a few numbers and
figures about Mount Everest.
But that's enough of
my holiday photos.
Our next Numberphile
video will be back
to business as usual.